matt was there a moment in your life
where you knew you wanted to be a
filmmaker
there wasn't one exact moment in my life
when i realized oh this is what i wanted
to do for the rest of my life
it was sort of a culmination of events
and experiences
going through college like many people
you're trying to figure out okay what do
i want to do
uh what am i good at how can i put
myself
to you know put my talents to best use
and it was one of those things where you
know i took a screenwriting class
i took a introduction to film class
and started kind of looking back at my
life
and some of the things that i did and my
own writing my own
you know talents and things that i was
interested in and
realized oh okay this is kind of
interesting maybe
this is somewhere that i can actually
you know make a career out of it you
know this is like i didn't even think
about oh you can actually make a career
as a writer as a director
and once that started hitting it became
sort of
like i'm sure for many people an
obsession and
you know just constantly just immersing
myself in
the world of filmmaking as much as
possible learning
uh practicing and kind of taking that
journey
to you know becoming a filmmaker when
you told your parents that you wanted to
be a filmmaker what were
their thoughts on that when i told my
parents that i was interested in
being a director they definitely were
kind of like wait
is that a real job you know what i mean
so they they were
kind of curious can you make a career
out of this can you make a living off of
this
like how is this possible
and you know once you once i went to
film school they started seeing my
projects
they noticed that oh okay so this is
this is what you do because
i come from a background where you know
my dad's an engineer
my mom was a nurse very sort of
practical
career choices so when they kind of
you know when they finally saw that oh
you can actually you get paid to
to write and direct movies like okay
that seems cool that seems fun
and then it was funny is for years i was
directing features like independent
films and
you know doing writing assignments and
scripts and they were always like oh
yeah
you know you're a director yeah that's
that's cool
but um i never worked with really huge
big name talent before so finally this
year when i
it's funny i finally worked with uh
bruce willis on a couple movies and
when my dad found it he's like bruce wil
like john mcclane i'm like yeah
yeah oh now he's like okay
so you made it you made it as a director
i was like yeah i was kind of there for
the last you know
few years but you know it's just now
that you know
they see it it's kind of cool was that
important to them to have their sort of
blessing
and not go into law or medicine or
because i think no matter what i would
have done the good thing is my parents
definitely were
supportive of that they helped me out a
lot they
kind of you know they were there for me
when i needed them
and there's these because the thing is
in your career you're always going
through ups and downs no matter what
especially towards
success it's never a straight line
upward
there's always those those little breaks
and then a bigger break and then a
stumble and then
you sell a script and then you think
you're going to be on set and then the
financing falls through
and then you get another movie green lit
but then it doesn't turn out the way you
thought and you thought it was going to
get into sundance and
it didn't get into sundance and then now
it's just released on
some vod platform and you're like okay
well okay
that was an interesting learning lesson
let's go on to the next project so
you know and through that i don't think
you could survive
as a filmmaker unless you have that sort
of like friends family
parents who are helping you and kind of
helping push you and promote you and
and being there to motivate you do you
like that challenge
there's some people they want sort of
this road map that's
just they know like point a is going to
lead to point b but i think some people
like puzzles and they like to be able to
figure things out especially if
somebody's almost like you can't do it
you know look i mean
it's interesting i mean obviously if i
hit the lottery
you know when i was you know a young
filmmaker and you know you could get
discovered and you did an amazing short
film and then next thing you know you're
on a big budget studio film and then you
know because that that happens right
that does happen
where you know you get discovered
quickly off of a short or a script and
then six months later you're on set
shooting it and then next thing you know
you're a studio filmmaker and
that does happen so it's there but at
the same time
you have to realize that that those sort
of exceptional stories aren't exactly
what is going to happen to you so you
have to kind of gear yourself and
prepare yourself for
yeah be cool if it happens but shoot a
short or reticle script and
you know it propels forward in an
interesting way but if not
you're gonna have to grind you're gonna
have to keep doing it you're gonna have
to keep shooting
keep writing keep producing keep getting
yourself out there
and that's a part of the process is that
persistence
you have to be persistent i mean that's
the one thing that i've seen
in my career as a filmmaker and as a
directors the ones that
are persistent even after failure
even after a little success or even
after a big success
they stay at it they just keep going
they keep trying pick themselves up up
and do it again
try again and then next thing you know
it's like oh wait it's been a few years
now i'm on set doing another movie like
you know what i mean so
that's what you have to do you have to
keep motivated and keep persistent what
does success
look like to you i think the definition
of success is different for different
people
for for me it was always just being able
to
have a sustained career as a director
and for me it was never oh until i'm
directing a 100 million dollar movie
with tom cruise i'm not successful like
you got to look at it as people are
looking to as a filmmaker as a director
they trust you
they look at your work and they find
somebody who they trust as
a voice and they give you the
opportunity to tell a story right
so for me it was always success was
always getting to that point where
i can make a living being a director
being a filmmaker
and getting people to pay me to do what
i love which is tell stories
create emotions create instagram imagery
and entertain audiences what about
having a paycheck but then the creative
control
might not be what one would think
and being able to reconcile that yeah
and say okay i'm actually doing what so
many people
come here to do or whatever and they
don't actually get to do it i get to do
it
yeah that's really cool but now i'm not
really i'm just doing
other people's work yeah well i feel
like
having complete creative control on your
work
is something that you have to earn it
takes a lot
to get to that place it takes a while to
build yourself
up as a director as a filmmaker to where
people trust that every creative choice
that you're gonna make
is gonna be something that will uh be
successful
so i think as a as a director i've
always
you know you know it's it's a
collaborative experience regardless but
being able to get to that place
where you know you either get final cut
or you're the one who's able to make all
the final decisions
creative decisions on larger projects i
think that is something that
you know getting to that place is
something you can aspire to
but you have to go into it knowing that
that's not where
we start as directors as filmmakers it's
a collaborative medium you have to step
in there thinking that okay
i have to you know the people that are
with me here
are all trying to do the same thing tell
a good story
make a good movie or shoot a good show
or
shoot a good video so you have to go
into it remembering that okay
everyone here is here for the same
reason and we're gonna all work together
to get to that
how did you get hired to direct game of
assassins game of assassins is a film
that
i worked on with a producing partner
from usc
so that's one of the great things about
making relationships with people
as you're progressing in your career you
know those people that you're with
whether it's with film school or whether
it's people you meet right out of film
school
or just through festivals those sort of
relationships
foster work and that's the brilliant
thing about you know when they say work
leads to work
and this town's all about relationships
that's what they mean they mean that
people that you keep in touch with and
who are working their way up in the
industry with you
they will be the ones that will be like
hey i got financing finally to do a
movie do you want to direct it and
you're like
hell yeah let's do it so it's one of
those kind of things those little
relationships where
you meet somebody you kind of do
something a little small together and
then
a year or two later that relationship
blossoms into something bigger
how do you research the industry and how
much time do you spend on it
i feel like the best way to research you
know the industry
or that you want to work in film is by
meeting people in the industry getting
to know the people
because that's really what it comes down
to is the people in the industry and the
people you meet
and the friendships that you make trying
to read a book
about how it is to be a writer or a
director or a filmmaker
is never going to really give you that
sort of
visceral right there kind of experience
of what it is
and you know you can do it as much
research as you want you can
listen to other people and talk to them
and
and do it but once you actually kind of
make those relationships
start doing it that's when it'll start
to crystallize and you're like oh that
one thing i heard that
this filmmaker used to always say about
you know shooting
these kind of films or these kind of
experiences it finally starts
crystallizing for you
so that's the best way and it's really
the only way to do it
when you wake up in the morning are you
like going to the trades online
and box office mojo or whatever just
trying to see
what's hot keep a pulse on things or is
that something you're too busy because
you're preparing for production or
editing whatever i think there is that
sort of balance where you do want to
keep
the pulse on what's going on right you
want to know
you know the world we're living in and
and and what's going
and what's happening but i think one of
the the pitfalls of being
in the industry is we have this little
bubble that we're in so everyone in
hollywood thinks they know
what the rest of the world wants right
but if they're living in this little
bubble
they don't realize that no there's
people in middle america
or all over the country or all over the
world that they really don't care what
this little bubble
has to say or has to do so i think
it's good to stand to know what's
happening in industry but at the same
time
you have to broaden your horizons and
it's much more important to know what
the world is doing what's going on
outside of hollywood or
la and california and los angeles so
that the stories that we tell
and the movies that we make and the
content that we make resonates with
the people that we wanted to right
is there a way to do that now without
becoming
too controversial or political is there
a way to tell a universal story
yeah i feel like stories no matter what
they are they're as long as you're
tapping into those sort of
universal themes the hero's journey
and those thematic elements that all
cultures and civilizations and peoples
deal with on a daily basis
the stories will resonate right you
don't need to find
what new twitter trend is cars and
controversy like oh let's make a story
about this
controversial twitter trend right those
things
date really fast they're things that
date quickly and
people want stories that they can kind
of universally go to
and you know what does it mean to be um
you know a girl that becomes a woman
going through that
adolescence or what does it mean to be a
father
and teach his son or you know these sort
of like universal stories of humanity
that we've had for
thousands of years those haven't changed
right
so as long as your stories are dealing
with those sort of elements
people will latch on to them and they
will resonate with them
you have two movies coming out that star
bruce willis so uh how did that happen
yeah sometimes when people kind of ask
me like oh you just did you know two
movies with bruce willis
you know starring they think it just
happened overnight or was one of those
things that like
you know that just kind of hit but you
know as a filmmaker i've been grinding
and doing it for more than a decade
right i mean i
went to film school a while ago and you
know i've been telling stories writing
scripts
making movies so to some people it feels
almost like this overnight thing but no
i've been
i've been at this for a while and it's
taken a while to get to that point where
my work is established enough where
people will come to me and be like oh we
want you to direct this film or
you know we've seen your work and we
feel like your style
your vision would really fit into the
content that we're creating
and that's how those films came about is
you know i did
several independent films that got a lot
of buzz a lot of attention
and they attracted producers who were
like oh hey we're doing these other
movies
are you interested we'd love to hear
your take on them
and it's a process it's like a job
interview right like you go in there and
you read the script
and you come up with your vision for how
you think that film
should be directed can we hear more
about this pitch
yeah when you're as a director when
you're going to direct a script from
another writer or like a studio project
or production company has
you have a certain freedom
to kind of read the script and come up
with your
vision for it and that includes
everything from a look book
to cast to how you think the world
is designed and looked and does and and
the visuals and everything just every
little detail
that you can go in there with describing
how you think that film should be made
and it's everything from
you know we're going to use a lot of
steadicam we're going to use handheld
we're going to use these kind of lenses
we're going to develop this sort of arc
with the characters
and and it's going in there with
a confident vision of how you think that
film
should be translated from the script to
the screen
and that's really what uh you know what
you're doing as a director when you read
someone else's script you're taking that
and you're sort of deciphering
how you think uh the best version of
that film
should be made how was it to have this
production company that was it that
worked with bruce or that knew
that had there was another company that
knew the company that worked
yeah approach you and
did you feel like you were validated
like okay now this is like a real
filmmaking thing yeah i mean i
definitely feel like it was uh it was
you know being able to get an approach
to direct a script from another writer
that has you know a-list talent like
bruce willis attached is definitely sort
of a oh
whoa this is finally you know a little
validation of my work
as a filmmaker that people are trusting
me with
telling this story so it was definitely
you know
it elevated the level of okay
the stakes are really high on this one i
really have to step it up and make sure
that
you know i really kind of bring in 100
of my passion and all the knowledge and
experience that i've learned as a
filmmaker
independent filmmaker for the last
decade about
okay how do you tell an interesting
story how do you you know incorporate
elements
of indie filmmaking which is kind of
like that
fast-paced quick uh shooting style into
a project where you have a little bit
more money to play with
but knowing that okay that doesn't mean
that you know you can get wild with it
right i mean there's still those
parameter
parameters of it's got to come in under
schedule under budget
and you want to be able to deliver the
film so that
people are always asking you for the
next one
and sorry did they sign on for both
movies or was it
one no you do one and then once you and
that's part of the experience right it's
like
and that's one of the things that that's
one of the lessons that you learn as a
filmmaker
throughout your career is and i've said
it time and time again as work
leads to more work so you do a project
you write a script for someone and then
they're like oh hey we're looking for a
director to direct this
other project that we have we really
liked your
script matt and that other film that you
did would you like to read this script
and give us your take on the project
so that's one of those things that both
as a
filmmaker and everyone in industry like
you work with a dp
he'll make a film he might meet with a
producer who will hire him on a film
that he ends up directing
or you know you work with an actor and
the film might turn out to be really bad
but
that actor was really incredible in the
film right so
you end up hiring him again on a
different film or
that's that's really what that's so much
of this industry and so much of
my career as a filmmaker has been just
one project
leading to the next in terms of the
relationships within that project
and the people you meet and the friends
you make and the collaborations that
happen
leading to the next thing what was the
emotion like
when you found out you got the was it
the first one
yeah and it was definitely the emotion
that i felt as soon as i realized
i was going to be directing you know
this film with bruce willis was
a lot of excitement i was just kind of
like whoa i better i better step it up
you know what i mean like i can't i
can't screw this up you know i gotta do
the best i can so
it was sort of like that nerve
nervousness mixed with
uh you know motivation drive more
dedication
like okay you know i got to step it up
and do do what i can
to to tell the best story possible and
direct the best film possible
within the constraints that i've been
given and um
i follow sort of like for me
i've learned to have more of a stoic
uh reaction in my career to things and i
think that
is what enabled me to have a sustained
sort of career is when bad things happen
you have to be able to kind of look at
it from a stoic mentality of okay
that sucks but we're going to keep going
and then when
something really amazing happens like
you're going to get to do or you've got
this cool thing or whatever
great i love that you know that's good
let's keep going let's keep moving
so it's having that balance where you
can kind of
not let it take you either one direction
or another
is one of those things that i learned
earlier on just reading about like stoic
philosophy and how stoicism helps
helps people in their careers and it's
something that goes back you know
to ancient ancient rome and it's just
something that i've learned
and even on set as a director i try to
have that sort of
stoic mentality on set because if you
have that confidence
and that so don't let the little things
that are going on on set
sort of drive you crazy because they
will you know i mean if you let
either the highs or the lows hit you
then
you'll lose that sort of control and you
want to be able to just go into it
confident almost like a chess match just
go in there with confidence
knowing that as things hit you you can
just
keep going take the hit or then you know
something great happens and like okay
this is great enjoy that little second
of it
and then just keep going don't let that
thing kind of don't ride that high to
the point where
it you know you forget what's what's in
the present what's in the moment what's
happening now
so that's really been my best bit of
advice is to
kind of like internalize that stoic
philosophy in your career
what does your tattoo mean this tattoo
is
actually a tattoo that i got when i did
my
film in china like i shot a film in
china
and it was a kind of a crazy experience
it was just being in a foreign country
and directing a film at a very young age
i was only
26 then i was directing my second
feature so it was it was a challenging
thing to embark at that young of an age
and a lot of responsibilities and we
survived
so you know i felt like i need to get
something to symbolize that survival
thing and what it is it's a quote from
the art of war
and it says uh whatever happens in life
you will always be victorious nice
i believe the mandarin is like
chanwabushan oh okay
do you speak mandarin no i did i learned
a few lines
a few words but that's about it that's
all i know
that's very cool how was it to be on
that set as
such a young director did you feel at
times that you really had to adopt as
you said earlier that stoic mentality
because people challenged you maybe
you were a threat maybe they thought
what does this guy know he's so young
yeah and and you had to really kind of
like
prove yourself but also show that their
daggers didn't affect you
yeah i feel like being
because i've had the fortune success
earlier in my career
when i was younger to direct a couple
features and i was 22 when i did the
first one and then 26 when i did the
other one
and wow you know so it was you know it
was young when i made those movies and
there's both pros and cons to to being
that young directing films and
one of them is you don't have the
experience yet and
you need to kind of get those life
experiences
to understand okay you know the human
relationships and the stories and
and there's always challenges that
happen in in terms of
you know being that young and having to
kind of command the respect of a lot of
people that are a lot older than you and
and
kind of just being able to stay focused
on your vision and
and challenges come your way you don't
have that life experience yet where you
can
fall back on a trust of oh okay this has
happened to me before
it's gonna be fine it's gonna be okay so
it's just one of those things and and
even them and myself
as a producer i would hesitate to hire a
director who is
you know a first-time director i mean
it's the idea of like oh
this girl or this guy has never directed
a film that's a that's a risk because
you never know what's going to happen
there's always that question mark and
until they've proven themselves
can you say like okay yeah it worked
they were able to step up to the plate
they were able to accept the challenge
and they were able to execute their
vision as close as they could
within the limitations and parameters of
filmmaking which is
you're never going to get 100 percent of
what you're over what you want because
there's never
infinite money or infinite days or
a perfectly cast movie where you
everyone's having like a the village of
the happy people or nobody everybody
gets along you know what i mean
that's just not how movie making is
there's always
personalities people budgets
schedules there's the logistical
challenges
of making a movie or making a show are
always going to cause conflicts
so no matter what you're going to have
to be able to
trust yourself as a director to tell a
story
and create as close as you can
the final product to that crazy idea you
had that vision that you had at the
beginning and
as close as you can get it is kind of
the goal
so sorry you were 26 when you went to
mainland china to shoot this
what do you think they saw on you aside
from your work
that they said i can trust him because
brilliant work is great but yeah that's
a lot well i feel like well
talking about relationships again and
the people that you worked with once
again those were
producers who i had met and worked with
after usc so we had that built-in sort
of relationship and that's why i was
saying
building relationships building
friendships and industry with people who
are like-minded
and developing those relationships over
the course of your career
are really what will afford you those
sort of opportunities because you're
never going to get
some random person like oh let me trust
you to you know for
five million dollars yeah go ahead go do
it no they're gonna need to be able to
say like
oh yeah we did that you know two hundred
thousand dollar
music video or short or script or
whatnot and
we kind of killed it so let's step it up
again and do something bigger
and that's how a lot of those
opportunities happen is
those relationships develop and mature
and
the opportunities come what would your
advice be for
a young director maybe it's not their
first time but they're being in
put in a situation that's super
impressive but they're also going to
another country where they may not be
familiar with the language the customs
and they know they have this huge
responsibility they don't want to show
they're nervous
but yeah they're terrified maybe well
it's it's funny is i also the one of the
very first movies that we just did we
did that in puerto rico
so i got to go to puerto rico as well
and that's the beauty really about being
a filmmaker sometimes is we get to
travel we get to go to
places we get to experience new cultures
and
you have to realize as a director that
the culture of the country you're in
affects the way that the crews are
and the crews work and you know the
hierarchies are a little different you
know the ad might be a little different
in one country in terms of how they
communicate to the crew
versus uh how it is in and where you're
used to right so i remember in puerto
rico one interesting thing that i
noticed was
uh the crews there love like enjoying
life
which is great but you know every time
we'd break for lunch
music was playing people were dancing
and having fun and
i was like whoa this is we got to go to
my door you know
i was like this is different you know
but you kind of just kind of
feel it out you're like okay this is
this is what the culture here
this is how they work right this is how
people here work and
we get stuff done so what does it matter
right i mean it's just
how things are made here and you know
maybe some of the set etiquette is
different
in terms of who talks to what and how
these
kind of things go down but you have to
trust your
instincts as a director and you know
when you get to set
sort of being able to decipher those
things as they're happening
is really all you can do i mean you can
ask questions you can learn
you can kind of research like we talked
about but ultimately it comes down to
getting there and doing it and that's
the only way you can actually kind of
decipher it
what makes a great story i think what
makes a great story is different
in a film than it is in a novel or
a poem or another form of art
with film it's it's a visual medium but
it's also
auditory and it's dealing with
a narrative structure that's different
from you know
like other mediums so to create a
great story in film it's a combination
of so many
things that it's almost like it's it's
hard to even decipher it down to one
thing it comes down to these magic
elements that just sometimes
happen right it's doing as much as you
can to tell an interesting story
with universal themes and great acting
and great cinematography and
beautiful sound design and all those
elements coming together
uh to create a great story
because i feel like you can have a great
script a great script in
in as a story but the final film could
not be great it couldn't
he could have not gotten there and why
because those other elements weren't
able to elevate
that great script and tell that great
story
so with film it's like you have to get
all those things together
deal with all the other logistics of
actually shooting a movie
and sometimes let those happy accidents
happen
so that that final product for whatever
it just all came together you know
sometimes you leave a set
after shooting a movie and you're like
there were some cool moments i don't
even know if we have a story that you
like did that work like you know what i
mean it's like god it was so tough
and then you get into the editing room
and you're like whoa that was a cool
moment or that was interesting
i never thought that that take would
have worked in that sort of way
so reshuffling scenes in the put in post
and kind of working all that out you
realize oh
so that's that that totally worked or
that that was what
made it elevated it to the next level
so that happens a lot i guess then for
probably many filmmakers where you
do your whatever 16-day shoot and then
you have all your footage and you're
driving back or whatever's happening
you're packing up the trucks and
do we even have a movie here and is that
like a do you think that's a common
i feel like for me as a director every
time i finish a movie it doesn't matter
how amazing the experience was
there's always that niggling thing in
the back your mind where you're
thinking god did i did i cover the
scenes like did we cover the movie like
do we did we miss any shots did we
you know it was that kind of thing i
mean there's always going to be that
little niggling thing in the back of my
mind at least
where i'm not 110 sure yet until i
actually get into post
work with my editor and start piecing
the pieces of the puzzle together
and that's one of the things that i've
learned over my career as a filmmaker as
a storyteller is
on set what you're trying to do is
you're just getting trying to get little
pieces
of the puzzle right this shot will get
this story
this element of the story told this
scene will be this piece of the puzzle
and it's about getting all those little
pieces of the puzzle so that once you
get into editing
all those like pieces kind of come
together and it's hard to know
when you're done oh all the pieces are
gonna fit perfectly right you try to
edit it in your head as much as possible
but at the same time there's always
gonna be that little thing and you have
to just
you gotta be confident enough to just
say okay let's let's keep going we got
it let's
let's do it so regarding action
in a film the long night and trauma
center
you have a lot of action scenes we talk
about your
preparation for those action scenes
directing action is definitely something
that was new for me
and it was something that you know i
love action i love action thrillers so
being able to get a chance to
to do an action movie was a lot of fun
and the preparation for that required a
lot more
in terms of understanding okay this is
what's
on the script how do we best execute
this
with the tools that we have with the
budget that we have
with the time that we have because
that's all it comes down to is being
able to like read what's on the page and
be able to
to execute that so it required a lot of
storyboarding a lot of shot listing
a lot of in-depth conversations with you
know the stunts
and the vfx and saying okay what can we
get away with or what you know
how what do you think in terms of okay
we got we got a car chase happening how
do we
execute this car chase in four hours
and we only have one camera on a russian
arm how do we how do we pull this off
right
so it's kind of digging into the people
around you your collaborators and who
have done it before
so that you can kind of see oh okay this
is this is what this is going to be able
to do and this is what this is going to
be able to
and for me an action scene has to serve
a narrative purpose in the story
so you can't just have a blind action
just because it's cool action scene
let's just blow something up or let's
just have a
fist fight to have a fist fight even
a car chase in a movie has to have a
beginning middle and end
and it has to have that narrative thrust
otherwise
it's just a random car commercial two
cars just
skidding through the skin through a road
right so i always
sit down there and challenge myself and
say okay if we cut this
action scene out what are we gonna lose
and
if we're gonna lose something then like
okay we need this action scene because
our character has a definite goal in
this action scene
and he's achieving that goal and the
antagonist
is for whatever reason blocking that
goal right
so it always comes down to that and
understanding how this
action scene is going to propel the
story forward
what's the hardest part of making a
movie and why
hmm that's a that's an interesting one i
think the hardest part about making a
film
is the logistics
sometimes it's those unknowable things
that you have no control over
and being able to it doesn't matter if
it's a 100 million dollar movie or
a 200 000 feature there's always going
to be things that come
up where you don't have control over
them right
so and that's just the nature of what we
do
is we're taking a camera and we're
pointing it at real people
in real situations and things in real
life
kind of always like things happen right
i mean you know this actor isn't
available or
you know thing going on the lights not
working the sun is setting we're losing
our light
uh the sound isn't what we thought like
there's
loud sounds here so there's these
unknowable things that are always coming
at you as a director and
you have to be able to filter out the
ones that are going to require your
attention
and the ones that you have to kind of
just move on from
so i think that's what it that's one of
those things that you can't really
learn you have to experience and kind of
have that sort of thing in your belt
where
this situation has happened to you
before where the sun is setting and you
have
five shots to get on your shot list and
crap okay how do we get this scene in
one shot now because the sun is setting
and that's when you're thinking as an
editor and you're saying okay
the previous scene we did this and there
was a shot where
our character walked from here to here
you know what i don't really need to get
that
transition moment let's just go straight
into him he's in the room
and it's coming it's being able to be
nimble on your feet and make those
adjustments and make those cuts
in your head so that you don't lose your
whole day
so that you know when the producers come
up to you and say did you get the scene
you can say
confidently we got the scene it cuts
together it works
is that where the sort of monk-like
stoicism
comes into play because like that i'm
sure that that sounds like you could
panic
too you could go either way on that one
yeah definitely those are those
situations where you have to
not let the outside distractions
kind of pull you away from what your
goal is as a director which is
you got to sit behind the monitor and
this is one word of
advice i got when i was in film school
was
ultimately the director is the ideal
audience
for a film so when they're sitting
behind that monitor or they're sitting
next to the camera
watching the actors looking at the scene
you got to look at it as a perspective
of an ideal audience member and be like
that worked or that's going to require
one more
or how is that going to cut to the next
thing right or as a storyteller you're
kind of putting yourself in that
position
and you're looking at it from that
perspective so
being able to just turn off everything
around you all the noise and just being
able to for that for that moment where
you call action and cut that little
in between just being able to look at it
as an audience remember that ideal
audience member and just taking it all
in
i think is critical to being able to
tell your story
when should someone quit their day job
to become a full-time
filmmaker director that's an interesting
question uh
i think that's always a challenge is
because i've had i've had to work with
that challenge as well as like when you
quit your day job
and focus just on your passions
directing writing producing whatever it
is
and it's funny is i really early on in
my career
you know i was lucky i said i was you
know young and i got to direct a couple
movies before the age of 26 and
and then it was like 2009 2010 and then
the whole economic recession happened
and
you know trying to maintain myself as a
director
filmmaker at that time was challenging
right so i had to get a day job i
started doing
um you know things not even related to
filmmaking i was
i got a day job uh in uh
tech in the tech field so i was doing
like qa software testing for companies
for a few years
and i was doing that until you know a
few years ago where i was like okay
like this is fine like i'm starting to
sell scripts again
i just did another film i got an agent
now i got a manager
i can focus more on uh
this path so it's and that's why i've
said it so many times to other
uh to other aspiring filmmakers and
directors is
your career is never going to be
sometimes it is
sometimes some people are lucky and they
hit it big
somebody sees their short film steven
spielberg sees their short film
or james wan sees their short says oh my
god get this guy a feature and then he
directs a movie with warner brothers and
then
actually you know he's doing a 100
million dollar movie and you're like wow
how did that person
get like that's what i want to do you
know what i mean but
chances are your career is going to be
more of that
you do something get some attention and
then people
don't really hire for anything and then
you have to start over again and do
another film and write another script
and then
try it again and then this time you get
to work on a little bit bigger budget
and then you learn about the process
more and you become a better storyteller
and then you're expecting that film is
going to open canon or
sundance you're like i made this
incredible
feature it's so cool it's going to get
into it's going to get so many festivals
and
you don't get into the festivals you
thought you were gonna get into
so now you're saying okay damn
i thought i was gonna have to quit my
job and then you know get a 100 million
dollar studio movie so that's not
happening now
so now i gotta you know get back to it
and grind again
write another script what's the type of
movie that i can make
another thriller or another comedy or
whatever so what's my
expertise and uh
you've got to go back at it again and
try again and and
shoot another one and eventually what
you'll look back on is you'll turn
around you'll look at
all that process and you're like wait a
second each one was just like a little
notch up that took you up higher and
higher
bigger budget bigger talent bigger
people more
exposure and next you know suddenly
you're like oh i don't even need a day
job anymore i just
quit and i'm making enough money doing
this that i can actually have a
sustained career as a filmmaker
was that your hardest year the 2009 time
yeah i mean there's there's always been
hard years and
and uh good years and successful years
and and
it's it's up and down it's hard to say i
could have a hard year in three years
now that's worse than that right
can make a movie and critics savage me
and stuff happens like oh well you know
that's the thing i've learned from
other successful directors and
filmmakers is they don't let that stuff
get to them they're just
they're working they're making films
they're telling stories
they don't let other people's opinions
on
whether they should be making films
affect them
they just do it they're like i'm gonna
keep making movies you know what i mean
it doesn't matter what
other people think of it it's like as
long as i'm getting the opportunity i'm
gonna keep doing it
so you have to kind of be that stubborn
dog-headed person where you're saying
this gives me joy and
i'm gonna keep doing what i have to do
to to get that
when you were working that um tech q qc
job or whatever
i'm sure your mind wasn't totally there
at times
you're right thinking about what's it
like you know i could do a script about
this or something you know no
it's definitely there was times where
yeah i mean um
[ __ ] i got fired from a couple jobs
because i was like not like showing up
you know what i mean because i was like
doing things that i should you know
showing up late and stuff but that's the
thing is
uh you know you have a day job you get
you do
to pay the bills sometimes like look we
aren't all lucky we're not all trust
fund babies
and we don't all have rich parents or
uh we don't inherit you know a lot of
money so
gotta get a day job and it's fine like
people
you know throughout their careers it's
okay to have a day job where
you're paying your rent and then when
you get you know wake up in the morning
i know
i was reading this thing where stephen
king before he was stephen king
he worked at like like a laundromat or
something right i mean
he was waking up early at 5 00 a.m
writing for 10 pages
then going to work then coming home and
then his wife was sick for a while he
was helping her
and then he'd write a little bit more
and then he was sleeping that's just the
reality of being an
artist is you know we don't really have
that freedom to just
you know wake up and instantly you know
we have
access to whatever we want we have to
sometimes grind at it and kind of get
ourselves there
was that in his book on writing i
believe so yeah such an excellent book
it is right it's great because you know
what was fascinating too is when he
talked about when he quote
made it then he had new challenges so i
think that's what's like this
misconception that you could be
okay now you're without the day job but
now there's a new challenge and that is
you're keeping track of your own time
you're keeping yourself on point 100 and
he talked about
how things got diverted a little bit and
then that was sort of an eye-opener for
me i didn't know
yeah no that that can happen is that's
the thing is when you
are actually making your art whatever
that is whether it's
writing or directing or cinematography
or
editing you realize okay yeah you don't
necessarily have a boss telling you
guys show up at 9am and you're leaving
at 6 or whatever
but at the same time you have to now
wake up in the morning be like okay
you know i'm going to create
work for myself somehow right i mean you
might not need to do work this week
because
you just did a job last week but at the
same time you have to realize
okay yeah you did a job last week you
directed a film
you know for three months but you never
know when your next film is going to be
it could take a while you could
be ready to go and you got another film
and then it falls apart and then it's
like
oh crap how do i pay my rent next month
you know what i mean so you have to go
into that mentality of
new problems and new challenges are
always going to be there and you need to
be prepared to
to deal with those it doesn't mean you
got to give up
your passion right just because you're
in a day job and
sometimes it's good to have a day job in
the actual industry that you're working
in so if you're a writer
it's great if your day job is reading
other people's scripts
because now you're learning from other
people or if your day job is
uh let's say you want to be a director
your day of job
is editing so now you're editing other
directors work and you're seeing oh
that was interesting or he screwed that
up or she screwed that up so
seeing what other people do will
definitely during that day job so that
when
you do get that opportunity you're using
all that experience
can you share five lessons that will
help someone be a better filmmaker right
now
i think five lessons that will make you
a better filmmaker
right now is first trust
your actors actors are always going to
come in there to try to elevate the
material
to try to create better work for you so
always trust your actors
number two don't get so trapped on what
your vision is that
you're so focused on it you can't listen
to other ideas or other people
because that'll limit what you can get
third is don't give up
you know what i mean if things aren't
exactly going your way
that doesn't mean that there isn't
something right around the corner
or something that you can do to kind of
get to that quicker
i think another tip is to
read a lot of scripts i think reading
scripts and then
watching the films that were actually
made off of the scripts
you'll learn so much about how the story
was actually executed
it's one thing to see a movie and be
like oh this is how i would have done it
or this is how i
they should have done it but when you
read the actual material that it was
based on the blueprint itself
and then see oh that was interesting the
way that that director
executed the scene or the blocking in
that scene
was was different than the way i would
have blocked that scene but
that was interesting uh another bit of
advice that i would give
is edit move
edit projects as much as you can because
the more as a director
you're on set thinking as an editor
the faster you'll be the more concise
you'll be
and the more able to get what you need
on set is because you've spent that time
in the edit bay
seeing what works seeing how cuts takes
and work to get cut together and
elements kind of don't you don't need
and things that you do need
really helps with that so i think
cutting projects
cutting stuff on your own is really
essential and i remember one of the
things that i didn't film school was
i would take a like let's say a scene
from
you know whatever your favorite movies
are whether it's lawrence of arabia
or the godfather or whatever you take
those films and you take a scene
you drop it on the timeline and you just
find all the cuts
for that scene and you notice and you
look at it and yet in whatever editing
program you're using like oh
so they cut from that to that to that it
really is a
invaluable way to see how a scene plays
out
how cuts he can get either shorter or
faster
how the director and the editor create
suspense or
tension by the way that the cuts are
laid out in the scene
so that was a really invaluable learning
lesson is by
looking at other projects and see how
they were cut
it's excellent yeah i like that yeah
it's really good yeah do you remember
the
the films you used to watch again oh
like some of the ones that really stuck
out where you
stuck out to me yeah um
trying to think that's i was oh okay
it's hard to it's hard for me to choose
five films or just a list of films that
had a lot of
uh you know that that kind of left an
impression on me as a filmmaker i think
more than anything it's uh you know the
directors themselves and their
body of work that i look back on and
kind of get inspiration from
like looking at kubrick looking at how
he was able to
kind of tap into different genres like
horror
uh the war films and all those different
genres that he touched on
how he would uniquely shoot a scene was
always interesting that would always
give me inspiration of like okay
you know i was that wasn't there was a
different way to shoot this scene so
i'll try to think of other directors or
other filmmakers
and see how at their work they might
have approached a similar scene and try
to be like oh
that's that's different i never would
have thought of that but that'll kind of
inspire me
as a filmmaker i mean kubrick spielberg
kurosawa uh christopher nolan
those are the type of filmmakers where
their work is so
unique and such a strong voice
that anytime i need inspiration and want
to just
kind of draw back into that creative
well i can just look at any of their
films and
find something unique or different that
will help like motivate me and inspire
me
and speaking of chess we talked about it
earlier in the interview
uh kubrick used to play chess for money
right when he was no he was yeah no
kubrick was uh he approached the
filmmaking process
like a chess game in a way right every
problem that came at him was you know
another move on
on the board and he would always try to
anticipate
two steps ahead other things that could
happen and it's
chess is not just an analogy for
filmmaking it's really an analogy for
life where you know if
you can become a good chess player then
you you know put your mind in that
mindset
you can become a better filmmaker and
hopefully a
better person because you can kind of
look at life in that from that
perspective
yeah he had a very unique way of looking
at the contrarian way
yeah in a lot of ways when you hear
interviews with him totally he was very
interesting guy
yeah very fascinating figure where does
the story begin for you like how do you
know the beginning of one
when you start writing or even you're
reading someone else's material
for me the beginning of a story is where
you're introduced to a character and you
can empathize with them
i think that's the point where the story
really begins
because until you can step into the
shoes of whoever your protagonist is
your story can't really start everything
up into that point is
things that you didn't necessarily need
and once that moment happens and it
clicks into place
that's when you're like okay now as an
audience member
the story begins and i'm following this
character's journey whoever they are
and seeing where it leads me you think
of
of a few characters where you were able
to empathize with them maybe they even
weren't someone that if you saw them in
real life you would really empathize but
once you see that
from that you know sort of director's
perspective well i think one of the best
examples
um and i think why this was a such a
successful show breaking bad
was walter white's character and i
remember
talking about um you know reading the
script
of something before you actually watch
it i remember reading the pilot for that
and it happens so quickly in that where
you step into walter white's shoes as a
character
you see the life he's leading he's a
teacher
he's got to deal with these students and
then he goes home and he has sort of
like this
contest relationship with his wife and
he finds out he has cancer and it's like
you're like whoa this guy's dealing with
a lot of issues and
you can relate to them right because who
has it in their life
you know woken up one morning and feel
like
they're living like the worst possible
version of their life
and there's all these things that are
happening to them and it's
it's you just relate to that right so as
soon as that happens in that story
you're already empathizing with walter
and
when he gets the opportunity to kind of
break bad as they as they said you're
you're with him right you want to see
how far he can take this
what's going to happen to him and i
think that's the key to interesting
stories is
getting you to empathize with you know
who your hero is so that when things go
bad or when they're making
sometimes really bad choices
you're not yelling at the screen you're
just saying ah it's that
he had no other like or she had no other
choice to make that was just like
they're putting these circumstances and
you're able to step into their shoes and
see from that perspective
and it's interesting too how his
character plays off the jesse character
right because jesse's situation isn't as
dire
and he's much more flippant and cavalier
about things whereas
the stakes for walter are much higher
he's got a
son that has um you know a disability
yeah and
you know you see these boys come in the
store or whatever and that scene right
there you really
feel you know the clothing store
wherever that they are and
if you were to see that normally you
think well this person is not a good
person but then
under in the context of why that
happened it makes sense so just
to see his character in these dire
straits and then played off the jessie
character who's
you know yeah he was just flipping about
yeah that was great yeah and i think
but i think that's the reason why walter
is the protagonist that shows right
that's the audience perspective into
this world is that character
and you can empathize with him and see
where he's coming from
who's been the best person you've ever
worked with in hollywood
and what was it about that individual
aside from their body of work maybe it
was just the way they worked with people
maybe it was how they handled themselves
in pressure situations
wow uh god call someone out
oh yeah you don't have to even say their
name okay i think the best person i've
ever worked with
is an actor that i got a chance to work
with recently
on a project and his name is shea
buckner and he was
one of the best actors i've ever worked
with and what it was was
he came in there so prepared
with so much backstory with so many
interesting choices
that it's a dream as a director when an
actor comes to you with just so many
interesting
ideas and so much of a fleshed-out
character
that that person on the page where
you're like oh
this is a cool complex character your
actor can just
take it to this whole other level and
just add
so much to it that every line has
backstory every little nuance has
some interesting subtext to it and
it just it challenged me as a director
to step it up and
tell an even better story because you're
working with these
actors who really they're committed to
those characters that they're telling
that they're creating right they want
their characters to
feel real and have a inner life and
come come to life on screen and that
really just it was an incredible
experience to work with such a
dedicated actor who just made me a
better director
so for that film did you have a table
read with the actress before
oh god i wish i did well you didn't no
you know wow
the tough thing about some of these
movies is literally actors are cast two
days before
you're shooting and you're like okay
we'll see you in two days
so it's challenge you don't do a table
read like i've had that i would love to
have a table read
love to have rehearsals sometimes the
nature of the beast is you don't have
time to do any of those and you have to
really trust your instincts
as a filmmaker and trust the actors
instincts and
be able to collaborate in a way such
that
you know the work is of high quality and
elevated still even though you didn't
get a chance to
to do a you know rehearsals on that and
it's interesting because
some directors don't even like
rehearsals
and they prefer not to do rehearsals for
me
and and i never understood that because
for me like
when you rehearse it's not like
you're never going to get that take
again right i mean i feel like people
are afraid to rehearse because they
think somehow
they're gonna get some magic and then it
wasn't on camera and then they'll never
be able to get something like that again
but
if you're working with talented actors
and you trust yourself as a director
there's no reason why you can't get
another one just like that or ideally
even
better than that and that's the thing is
once you've directed enough and you've
seen
the contributions that an actor makes to
a scene with their characters
i see now why some directors like the
finchers of the world
shoot 40 takes or 30 takes or
i would love to keep shooting because
every take
it's another layer that's added it's
something different it's an interesting
choice
those sort of natural
things start really start coming out and
that's why theater
you know when you have an actor who and
you have a group of of actors doing
something every night for
months on end by the time they're done
they're just
there's so much going on that it's just
it's on another level so anytime i you
know hear a director say oh i don't like
doing rehearsals i'm like
why i mean every time you're doing it
again you're getting a chance to
bring something else to it you try
something different sometimes it doesn't
work but
that doesn't matter you have another
chance to try it again and
do something different so i think
rehearsals are really important
part of the process and anytime you can
get afforded to get them
definitely take them and don't turn them
down because that's really where you can
find
those nuances and those little moments
is
through rehearsing with the actors and
talking through it and finding them
together so when he showed up on set was
it like 6am call
time or whatever and did you just know
in that moment like oh wow this guy is
super
he's right now i mean i think uh as soon
as you meet an actor
well i had conversations with him like
the day before
so i knew like in getting on a skype
call like
okay this person is prepared they have a
really strong take on the character
and it's really going to elevate the
material and it kind of gave me that
boost of confidence and inspiration
that you know i'm working with these
individuals these doctors that
are really committed to creating great
work and
you know as a director you come in and
you do all that you can to really kind
of just
push the material and elevate the
material so when you do work with
collaborators who come at that
with that same angle it really keeps you
motivated and pushes you to keep going
and to keep doing better